STEWART REICHLING:
Hey, everybody.
My name is Stewart
Reichling from Google Cloud.
I'm a product manager
working on Traffic Director.
With me is Kelsey Hightower.
He's going to be
doing a demo later.
Today we're here to
talk about building
an enterprise-grade service
mesh with Traffic Director.
So I'm going to go through
a little bit of pretext
and prelude for why a
product like Traffic Director
even exists and why
you should consider it.
Then we're going to talk about
what Traffic Director is.
We're going to go into
an awesome demo that's
going to give you a
good sense of how do
you interact with this product?
How does it actually work?
We'll talk through
some of the problems
that customers are solving
with Traffic Director,
and then we'll go into
some of the announcements
that we're going to make today.
So what is Traffic Director?
To understand
Traffic Director, I
think it helps to kind of think
through a very simple model.
So I talk to
customers all the time
who are dealing with
problems like a retailer
who wants to try to make their
deployment production ready.
And so as a retailer, you might
be doing very retail things.
You have a
shopping-cart service.
You have a payment service.
The shopping-cart service
helps your customers add items
to their carts, and
then a payment service
allows your customers
to pay for the stuff
that they want to buy.
Really straightforward
stuff, right,
the types of things
that you might
want to solve as a retailer.
Let's look at what
that looks like
once you start trying to
make it production ready.
And so here I have some code.
It's not great.
It's the type of
code I might write.
It's a checkout function,
a charge_customer function,
and then a function that
calls on both of those, very
straightforward, the
types of things that you
might want to do as a retailer.
And you'll notice here that
there is this line of code that
is the payment endpoint.
This is the endpoint that
the shopping cart uses
when it wants to call
the payment service,
and it's pretty straightforward.
Customers aren't really
doing this stuff anymore,
but kind of bear with me.
It's an IP address that
the shopping cart's
going to call on.
And you'll notice that
this simple model, you've
got some business logic.
You've got some
nonbusiness logic,
which is that payments endpoint,
pretty straightforward,
and small business logic.
Not too bad.
You're just calling this
thing from your shopping cart.
And now you get to a
production scenario
where you need to make
this thing something that
works for the holiday season.
And during the
holiday season, you
might have a lot of customers,
and you can't really
afford to have your payments
back end be overloaded,
and so what do you do?
You need more capacity.
Well, one way you
get more capacity
is you create another
payments back end,
and your shopping
cart now needs to be
able to call both
of those back ends.
So if one of them is
overloaded, well, that's OK.
You've got another one.
You can't afford to have your
payments failing because that's
money left on the table.
And so you have two instances
of your payments back end.
Your shopping cart needs
to kind of figure out
how to send traffic
between them.
We'll go back to our code, and
here's the exact same snippet
I showed before.
I hid some of the checkout
stuff because you're
going to see this starts to
become pretty clunky pretty
fast.
So rather than calling
the one payments endpoint,
we need to be able to call
two payments endpoints.
In fact, we need to be able
to load balance between them.
And so one way that you
might do this is you
might write a load-balanced
endpoints function.
And so rather than calling
just that one endpoint,
10.0.0.5, you now have
this 10.0.0.6 as well,
and you randomly choose
between one of them.
This is a pretty
straightforward,
not-too-complicated way of
implementing round-robin load
balancing.
Occasionally you'll send
traffic to one endpoint.
On other occasions, you'll
send traffic to the other one.
And so this gives you a
pretty straightforward way
to just load balance
between both of those
payments back ends.
But one of the things
that you'll notice here
is that whereas before I only
had that one endpoint, now
I have two endpoints.
I've also had to think
about how I choose
between those endpoints,
how I load balance
between those endpoints.
And take a second to
pause and put yourself
in the shoes of a retailer.
What does this stuff have to do
with selling goods and services
and products to your customers?
Well, not very much, but
you're now responsible also
for figuring this code out
and owning and maintaining
this code.
Pretty straightforward.
We just figured out how we could
add another payments back end
and load balance between them.
But you'll also
notice that if you
look at your
shopping-cart code, you're
now spending more of your time
on this nonbusiness logic.
And what I mean by
nonbusiness logic here
is basically code
that doesn't have
very much to do
with you delivering
your business at all.
It has to do with things
like resiliency and uptime
and dealing with big
problems that you
might face that are
more infrastructure
level than actually delivering
goods to your customer.
So OK, you just got a
little bit more capacity
for your holiday season.
Well, now we have
a new requirement,
and that's we can't just
randomly choose an endpoint.
We want to make sure
that the shopping cart
only calls on payments
back ends that are healthy.
And so rather than
just randomly choosing
one, which is what
we did here, is
we are going to actually
test those endpoints,
make sure that they actually are
healthy before we send traffic
to them.
And so rather than
get_load_balanced_endpoint,
we update that function
to be get healthy load
balanced endpoint.
And you'll notice there's even a
function here is_healthy, which
I don't know how to write this.
Basically what this would
do is figure out-- it's
got that IP address, 10.0.0.5.
Is it actually healthy?
It would go and check.
get_healthy_endpoints would look
at, for each of the endpoints,
whether they are healthy or not.
And suddenly that chunk
of code that you're owning
grows more and more towards
infrastructure-level problems,
networking problems, and
that's where you're dedicating
more and more of your time.
And so again, like we saw
before, your code that
is nonbusiness logic
continues to grow.
And again, I need
to ask you, what
does that have to do
with selling goods
and services to your customers?
Well, not very much.
And the examples I just showed
you are pretty straightforward,
ones that a lot of
customers might face.
Well, I talk to customers who
ask for all kinds of things
that I would put in the
nonbusiness-logic category.
My customers have requirements
like I have payments back
ends or other back ends in
multiple regions and clusters.
I need to be able to
gracefully handle timeouts.
I may be handling
private information.
That needs to be encrypted.
Tracing and logging code
needs to be in there too.
Dynamically scaling up
different payments back ends.
I might even have
development teams
that want to operate in
multiple different languages.
And so all of these
things I would posit
are nonbusiness logic, and
your engineering efforts
go to more and more handling
infrastructure concerns, which
takes away focus and resources
from delivering your payments,
from delivering
your shopping cart,
from delivering your
actual business.
And so the good
news is the example
I just showed you is a
little bit contrived.
We've already found
ways to solve this.
Customers have for a long
time been doing things
like running a load balancer
in between the shopping
cart and the payment service.
And so here, that load
balancer is basically a proxy.
The shopping cart
sends traffic to it.
The load balancer figures out
where that traffic should go.
All of your nonbusiness logic
lives in that load balancer.
But even this
pattern has its flaws
which is that load
balancer sits in between,
but you might have more and
more client instances sending
traffic through it, and that
starts to become a bottleneck.
You now have to figure out,
how do I scale this thing up?
How do I make sure
it doesn't go down?
because it's a single
point of failure.
And you even see other patterns
emerge that I would also
characterize as smells.
You might have, for
example, a support service.
Which support's important,
don't get me wrong,
but at the end of the
day, your customers
are paying for
goods and services.
They're not paying for support.
And so that's maybe a
little bit less critical,
but I see plenty of customers
who are sending traffic
from both shopping-cart
critical services
and support-front-end
less critical services
through the same proxy.
And again, you've got those
issues around scaling,
making sure it doesn't go
down, but then also you
have this configuration
that now lives
in your proxy belonging to
multiple different types
of services.
You need to make
sure that if you
make a change to the
support-front-end proxy code
it doesn't cause an issue
for your other services,
and so now you're dealing
with isolation problems.
And again, all of these
things go back to the idea
that you aren't really
delivering value
to your customers
when you're working
through these types of problems.
Over the past couple
of years, we've
seen a pattern that
helps us to solve this,
and the idea here is you have
a dedicated client-side load
balancer.
Often that is a sidecar
proxy, and so that
might run right next
to your shopping cart.
On the left-hand side, you
see an individual instance
of that shopping cart.
It has its own
sidecar proxy that
only has logic for the
shopping-cart routing,
for load balancing
for the shopping cart.
And if you want to
scale up and you
have another
shopping-cart instance,
well, that has its
own sidecar proxy.
And so both of those
can independently
load balance between
your payments back ends.
If one shopping-cart instance
or one shopping-cart instance's
sidecar proxy misbehaves,
the other one is unaffected.
And so this gives you a
really nice, simple way
to have client-side
load balancing.
You get rid of those concerns
around bottlenecks of things
that sit in the middle.
You've got configuration
that's highly tailored just
to that shopping cart.
It's not shared across
multiple services.
That's what the
sidecar-proxy model
that we've seen in the last
couple of years can do for you.
And so far, so good.
You've basically solved a lot
of the problems I described
earlier, but now you're getting
yourself into a new game,
and that is that you
need to figure out
how you're going to
configure that sidecar proxy.
So one way you might do that--
and I just made this up.
This is a proxy.conf file.
Imagine a JSON file
or a YAML file.
It contains the configuration
for your sidecar.
It has the endpoints for
the payments back ends.
It has maybe how you're going
to do health checks for those.
It's got the information
that the proxy needs in order
to support that shopping cart.
And so OK, fine.
Writing a proxy.conf for one
sidecar proxy, no big deal,
right?
And so what happens when you
have a new payments back end?
Well, you're configuring
your proxies again.
And so a way to do
that is you write
yourself another proxy.conf.
And I think you can already
see where I'm going with this,
but you've now
effectively started
to take on this additional
responsibility, which
is how do I write, distribute,
store proxy configuration?
And in this case, this
is still pretty trivial.
When I talk to customers who are
doing really enterprise-grade
stuff, they have departments
that look far more complicated.
They have deployments
that look more
like this, multiple
regions, multiple services,
some even hundreds or
thousands of services, each
running their own
sidecar proxies or middle
proxies with things like
encryption turned on
or different
load-balancing policies.
And so now you've got
yourself into the game
of writing and configuring
proxy.conf files.
And if you talk about expanding
the number of services,
expanding the number of
regions, this all just
becomes way more complicated.
You see customers doing
things like checking these in,
have validation in place
for proxy.conf files,
figuring out how to
make sure that there's
no issues in those
proxy.conf files.
And I'll go back to the thing
at the very beginning which
is if you are a
retailer, what does
that have to do
with selling goods
and services to your customers?
And again, people
have solved this.
There's a solution for it.
It's called a control plane.
And so the control
plane is a service that
is basically responsible
for writing, distributing,
making sure proxy.conf gets
to the right sidecar proxies.
It might have an API.
It might have different checks
to make sure the sidecar
proxies are helpful.
And you've probably
seen things like this.
For example, Istio
is a great example.
Istio has a component
called Pilot.
And all that really
is a control plane
that runs in your cluster.
You have some APIs
to tell it, hey,
this is what the world
should look like.
These are the policies
that I want to enforce.
And then Pilot will take
that and go and distribute it
to all of your sidecar proxies.
And so I talk about Pilot as
an example of a control plane.
Another example of a control
plane is Traffic Director.
Traffic Director is a
control plane as a service.
It's a GCP-managed service.
I'll talk a little
bit more about what
makes Traffic Director special.
But at its core,
it's a control plane.
You don't have to install it,
update it, any of that stuff.
It runs within GCP.
It knows about the world
because you tell it what
the world should look like.
And it also collects
signals really
intelligently from
your infrastructure,
and it generates that
configuration for your proxies.
And so what is Traffic Director?
Well, there's four things that
I want you to keep in mind.
Traffic Director is a universal
managed control plane.
And so what do I mean
when I mean universal?
I mean one part of that is
that it's global by default.
It looks at your whole
network as a global thing,
and so that includes not
just containers but also
virtual machines.
Plenty of customers aren't ready
to go 100% into Kubernetes yet,
and that's totally OK.
Whether you're on
VMs, on containers,
Traffic Director really
doesn't make a distinction
about which services
it's supporting.
If it's got, for
example, an Envoy
proxy on the virtual machine
or on the container that
connects to Traffic Director
using a set of APIs known
as the XDS APIs,
Traffic Director
will send a configuration back.
And the other thing that's
really cool that Traffic
Director is it's not just GCP.
We're starting to now have--
and you'll see more
about this later.
Customers have
deployments in GCP
and non-GCP environments
and other clouds.
And so for us, being
able to support
those other environments
is really key.
You'll see in a second about
what that means practically
in terms of what
we're delivering,
but just think of Traffic
Director as global,
as something bigger
than just GCP,
as something that's
bigger than just VMs.
So if I can reinforce
that further,
it's the fact that
Traffic Director is
more than just a service mesh.
Service mesh is a
type of deployment
that Traffic
Director can support.
It works really well
with service mesh.
But we're also starting
to see customers working
with more than
just these sidecar
proxies deployed in
the service mesh.
We're starting to see customers
who are using application
libraries without
proxies, and we'll
talk about what that
means in a second as well.
And also we're seeing customers
who are just deploying an Envoy
proxy on a virtual machine
that acts as a load
balancer, similar to that
model I showed earlier,
the one before the
sidecar-based model,
where you don't necessarily
have to be ready to add sidecar
proxies everywhere to get
value from Traffic Director.
Our goal is to support
a lot more than just
the traditional
model where you have
sidecar proxies next to
your application workloads.
We want to follow you
where your deployment is,
and what your topology
looks like is something
that we want to support.
The third thing to keep in
mind is that's programmable.
So we've got API that you use
to configure Traffic Director.
We've got a rich
set of policies--
so traffic-management policies,
layer-7-based policies.
We've got a lot of other
interesting policies coming up
as well.
But this gives you
a centralized way
to manage all of
your configuration
and your policies
in a single place.
You don't need to worry
about distributing policies,
about sort of handcrafting them.
It's a programmable
interface that you
can use to configure
your application network.
And then finally-- and this is
what really distinguishes it
from a lot of other
solutions-- is
it's a control
plane as a service.
What I mean here is that it's a
managed service managed by GCP.
It's got an SLA.
Our SREs are kind of making
sure that it doesn't go down,
and if there is an issue, we're
taking care of that for you.
It gets rid of a
lot of the things
that I would call not really
related to your business around
how do I install
a control plane?
How do I keep it up?
How do I make sure that the
state of my control plane
is replicated across
multiple regions?
These are all really
fundamentally difficult
problems that if you're a
retailer, if you're a bank,
if you're a
pharmaceutical company,
that's not really your
business, and you're not really
deriving much value from
taking on that responsibility.
And so with that,
I'm going to pass it
on to Kelsey who's
going to make it real.
He's going to show a demo.
Kelsey, off to you.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: All
right, thank you, Stewart.
So we're going to
jump right into it.
As we just talked
about, Traffic Director
is kind of center for all
of our service configuration
and the heart of our
service mesh in GCP.
It's often paired with
a thing called Envoy.
So sidecar, some people
look at it as just a proxy.
The nice thing about it is
Envoy supports the standard xDS
protocol for its configuration.
That means I can point
it at Traffic Director
to grab all this configuration.
A lot of you will be familiar
with a similar process
that you see in
something like Istio,
but what happens if the overhead
of having an additional sidecar
like Envoy becomes
too high, maybe
for a high-performance scenario?
Or what about the
management overhead
of having to manage another
binary and its configuration?
And the interesting thing that
we're going to talk about today
is proxyless service mesh.
If you think about
it, there's lots
of high-performance
frameworks out there.
GRPC is one of my favorites.
Inside of gRPC, we now have
native xDS integration.
So what does that mean?
Well, it means that
we can actually
get our configuration
from Traffic Director just
like Envoy.
And once we have
our configuration,
we can actually have
back ends, and we
can do some of the
traffic-management features
that you normally find in a
broader service mesh or a proxy
like Envoy.
Now to set this up,
we need some services.
Now, I can run my
services on VMs,
but Kubernetes is one of
my favorite platforms.
So what we're looking at here is
just a basic Kubernetes cluster
called next.
If I were to drill into
this Kubernetes cluster,
I have a deployment
of my calculator app,
and I'll show you
how that calculator
app works in a moment.
Just know I have a
set of containers
deployed to Kubernetes.
Now, I have three of
these, and they're
set up with an auto scalar
to go up to 10 if I need it.
Now typically when you
have multiple instances
of something, you'll typically
have a load balancer, so
let's click into that.
So here is my service
configuration.
You'll notice this is just a
standard Kubernetes Service
object.
There is no load
balancer at all.
All I have is a collection of
pods and their IP addresses.
So we're going to need
something else to handle
the load-balancing
aspects for us.
Now the nice thing about this is
the proxyless gRPC integration,
we can actually do
this on the client side
by getting the configuration
from Traffic Director.
So before we do that,
we need to make sure
we understand how the
calculator app actually works.
So the thing you
have to keep in mind
is we're not going to change
the way we write code here.
For example, I can write a
standard gRPC application
and test it on my laptop,
so let's do that now.
I'm just going to cd into
this calculator directory.
This is where the
source code lives.
And here's the server instance.
I'll just go ahead and
build that really quickly
so I can actually take
a detailed look at how
it actually works.
Now, the server calculator
app, all it does is builds
an endpoint where I
can call an add method
and give it an array of numbers
and have it give us back
a result. Once that's
done compiling,
we'll run it right
here from my laptop.
So here we go.
We'll run that here.
So you can see
that it's starting,
listening on port 5051,
commonly the default gRPC port.
And I also have my health
checks on port 8080.
So that's running locally here.
The next thing we'll do is
we'll take a look at the client.
Now the client-side code
is pretty straightforward.
I'll cd into that directory.
And then what we'll
do here is I'm
going to compile the client.
And this is going to
be a very standard kind
of request-and-response
gRPC application.
So as we're building our
client, once it's set up,
we'll take a look at
its command-line flags
to see what options we have.
All right, so now that
the client is built,
let's take a look
at those flags.
And we'll see that we can
give it a calculator flag,
and we can tell it where the
calculator service is running.
So by default,
it's going to look
on service host on port
50051, and then we can give it
a list of things to calculate.
Pretty straightforward.
So let's just run that now.
So we'll say client,
and then we'll
give it a couple of numbers.
We'll say 10, 20.
And you don't have
to be great at math
to get the answer for
this, and we can see
that the result is 30, right?
Pretty straightforward.
Now, what if we want to send
our application the server
somewhere else?
Well, remember, I packaged
up that server component
into this calculator app
that's running inside
of GKE or Kubernetes,
and you'll see here
that we have multiple
instances running.
Ideally, you want a HA service.
And then we also have
it configured to listen
onto this port, 50051.
Now, what if I
wanted to actually do
this from a virtual machine
and no longer on my laptop?
Now we have to deal with
the complexities of service
discovery and making sure
that we can load ballots
across all of those back ends.
So the first step
we've got to do
before we can do
anything else, we need
to configure Traffic Director.
So I'm going to pop over
to Traffic Director.
Now what you'll see here is
that I have one service healthy.
But if I scroll
down here, you'll
actually see
something interesting.
You'll see that I have one
network endpoint group.
When I created my service
instead of Kubernetes,
I told the GKE cluster
to actually manage
a network endpoint group that
has all those pods behind it.
So if we have 3
or 10, all of them
will be grouped behind this
network endpoint group.
You also see this
green checkbox here.
What this is saying is
that Traffic Director
is doing its own
set of health checks
to make sure that
all of those pods
are actually healthy
before we send
the configuration with
those back ends in it
to any client-side gRPC
application looking to leverage
these.
The last thing we need here
is also how do we communicate
what service do we want?
And this is where some of the
routing rules come into play.
Now if you have any experience
with Google Cloud load-balancer
products, this is going to
look very familiar to you.
First, we're going to start
with the gRPC protocol.
We're going to associate
a set of services
that we created early
in the Services tab.
And if you click on calculator
here, what we'll see
is that we give it a
couple of name matches.
So here, calculator plus
that port combination
will route us to this gRPC
service called calculator,
right?
So now all the configuration
is set on the server side.
Now the next thing we have
to do on the client side
is we need to tell
gRPC how to do this.
Now you're probably
thinking, do I
have to rewrite my entire
application to make this work?
Well, the good news is
with one import statement,
we can make this
work automatically.
I'm just going to pop
over to GitHub really
quickly so we can actually
see what the code looks like.
So here we're going to
click on our main code.
I'm just going to
zoom in a little bit
here so we can see
what's going on.
This is the only import
that we have to do.
And if you look
at this, we're not
going to actually
use xDS anywhere.
We're just going to load
the client-side load
balancing and service-discovery
components that
make it compatible
with Traffic Director.
So this is an xDS-compliant
client-side load balancing.
So with that in place, we've
got one more step that we need.
We actually have to
tell that bit of code
where Traffic Director is.
So here we have a service URI.
So this is going to be
our xDS control plane,
in this case, Traffic Director.
We're going to use our
server's account credentials
so we can authenticate to it.
And when we register
with Traffic Director,
we have to pass a little bit
of information about ourselves,
mainly our project number and
what network we care about.
Now, one thing to
keep in mind here
is my Kubernetes
cluster is running
in a network in my VPC called
Google Kubernetes Engine.
And that's super
important, and we
had to let Traffic Director
know that's the network that we
would like to find services in.
And the last thing
is Traffic Director's
really intelligent about routing
our traffic to, let's say,
the nearest zone.
So if I'm in US 1-a and I have
multiple Kubernetes clusters
with the same
application deployed,
it will be nice to have
Traffic Director use
our locality
information to give me
an optimized set of back ends,
maybe for things like latency
or, if a zone is
down, redirected me
to another zone
that's available.
All right, so now that we have
all the configuration, well,
let's copy this
client binary to a VM.
So what we're
going to do here is
I'm just going to copy
the prebuilt binary to one
of our VMs that I have
in my infrastructure.
So we'll just take a look
at that calculator binary.
Make sure that we have
it for the client.
You see it here.
And what I'm going
to do really quickly
is I'm just going to scp
this binary to a little VM I
call proxyless-grpc.
So let's just run that
command really quickly.
So what we're
going to do here is
we're just going to copy
this binary that I just
ran on my laptop, unmodified
code, to that virtual machine.
And now what we're going to do
is SSH to that virtual machine.
And once we're on
that virtual machine,
we'll have the ability to
run the same code again,
but this time we're going to try
to hit the containers running
in Kubernetes.
So we need a couple
of things first.
We need to make sure that
our environment is set up
correctly.
We have to tell xDS where
our bootstrap file is.
So you'll see this
environment variable
being set to my
local file system
where the xDS bootstrap
configuration file is.
So we'll just source
that to make sure
that our environment is ready.
And this time, we're going to
do something slightly different
with our client connection.
So we're not dealing
with localhost anymore.
We'll do something
slightly different.
With our calculator
flag, we're going
to give it the xDS schema,
and what this will do
is it will tell the xDS library
and all our client-side load
balancing to look up the service
inside of Traffic Director.
That's going to be
just enough so it
bypasses the normal lookup
service, in my case,
DNS by default.
Let's give it a couple numbers.
We have 1 and 56.
We'll run it now.
And we see that we
get the results of 57.
Just to make sure that
this is a live demo,
let's just pick some
random numbers here.
1 plus 999 is 1,000.
Everything is working great.
And I know you
might be thinking,
this is a virtual machine.
How hard would it be to install
Envoy in the virtual machine
and just use Envoy to
keep everything standard?
And you'll make a good point.
It doesn't necessarily address
the need for high performance
if you want to avoid the
proxy, but you're right.
On a virtual machine,
we do have the ability
to just run Envoy as
a sidecar right there
on the virtual machine and
bypass doing any of this.
So there's another thing
that I wanted to try.
Now, this might get me in
trouble with the PM team
because this is not something
that we advertise as working,
but what's a live demo without
a little bit of creativity?
One environment
that I like a lot
and really makes sense for
a proxyless integration
with Traffic Director
is Cloud Run.
If you're not familiar
with Cloud Run,
it's our serverless offering
where I can run my containers.
So earlier we just showed
running on a laptop,
running on a virtual machine,
but think about Cloud Run.
I don't have the
option of running
any additional sidecars.
I can only provide my
application, and that's it.
So in this particular
environment,
it's pretty constrained
in terms of what I can do.
So the nice thing about this
is I have the ability now
to do the exact
same thing that I
was doing on that
virtual machine
on a serverless
offering like Cloud Run.
You'll even notice
here that I'm passing
in the command-line flag that
matches the exact same one
that I was running earlier.
Now, we did something a
little bit different here.
I took all of that client
code that you saw earlier,
and I moved it into
an HTTP handler.
So if this is all
working, I should
be able to call curl,
hit the Cloud Run URL,
and then the client
code will basically
use the same address that
we were using before,
call out to Traffic Director,
get all of the back ends
that it needs to
route traffic to.
Now, there's one
more gotcha here.
Cloud Run runs in a slightly
different network than my VPC,
so I had to set
up one more thing.
Before I could run
my application,
I had to set up a VPC connector.
Now in the serverless world,
we can set up these connectors
to be very specific
to a specific network.
In this case, the Google
Kubernetes network
that I have set up earlier is
where my Kubernetes cluster is
running and all of
those containers,
and it also matches
the configuration
that Traffic Director has.
All I'm doing here is setting
up this serverless connector
called calculator.
So when I deploy my
Cloud Run application,
I can also give it
that VPC connector name
to ensure that when this
container starts up,
it will also be able to
have a leg into that VPC.
And the last thing, we can
also replicate the fact
that I have this xDS
bootstrap config inside
of this environment
variable letting
me know where to resolve,
just like in the VM.
And we'll take one
more peek at something
else just to make sure we're
all clear on how this actually
works.
If I go over here
to the calculator,
I want to show you
the Docker file
that I used to create
that container.
I want to show you that
we don't actually have
to change our code too much.
There's a lot of noise here,
so I'm going to break it down.
I'm building the calculator
app just like I built earlier
on my laptop.
The big difference
that I'm doing here
is I'm taking the
binary from this step,
and I'm also copying in
this xds-bootstrap config
into the container image.
Now, the nice thing
about that is I
have all the things I
need necessary to call
Traffic Director.
And I run one deployment script,
and if everything is working,
I should be able to call
that particular endpoint.
So I have my curl command.
This is the URL from Cloud Run.
And what we'll do is we'll
pass in a few integers here
to see if we can get
this calculation.
You can see it coming
up pretty fast.
Those are pretty big
numbers, and some of you
may be struggling with
math, so let's just
make it slightly
easier for the viewers.
So we'll give you
1, 3, and 5, and you
see that our answer is 9.
And with that, I would like
to end this presentation.
As you can see,
Traffic Director is
super flexible in terms of
implementing a standard xDS
protocol.
Combine that with
proxyless gRPC integration.
We can now take a standard xDS
client, run it on my laptop,
a virtual machine, or even
a serverless environment
like Cloud Run,
and we don't have
to match any other
binaries to get
what feels like a native
service mesh integration.
And with that, back
to you, Stewart.
STEWART REICHLING:
All right, nice.
Thank you very much, Kelsey.
So far we've gone
through context
on why something like Traffic
Director exists, what it is.
Kelsey brought it to
life by showing you
how someone might
interact with it,
what are some of the really
cool things you can do with it.
Another thing I
wanted to get into
is just what I see
customers actually
using this product for because
it's good to understand it.
It's good to see some hands
on, but what are real problems
that customers are solving
when they use Traffic Director?
And I'm going to
interweave in this
some of the new announcements
that we have as well.
And so let's go back to
the case of a retailer.
And I know I keep harping on
these large global retailers,
but I think they're a great
example because in retail, you
really can't afford
any downtime.
And so something like
Black Friday coming up
where every single second
is money lost if you're down
is exactly where a product
like Traffic Director shines.
And so what you see in
front of you right now
is an example of the
type of deployment
that you might see
with Traffic Director.
So we've got Traffic
Director running separate
from your regions, separate
from your deployment.
It's a managed service that you
don't have to manage yourself.
And here we've got an
example deployment where
you're in multiple regions.
You're in uscentral1.
You're in asia-southeast1.
You've got replicas
of the same services.
So you might have a retail front
end hosted in Kubernetes Engine
in both us-central1
and in asia-southeast1.
You have that because some
of your customers maybe
you are in the US.
Other customers are
in asia-southeast1.
So you want to make sure that
when they send you a request,
it goes to the nearest services
so you reduce your latency.
You reduce your
network travel costs.
You also want to
make sure that you've
got replicated services
in case one goes down.
And so what I'm
going to show you
is how Traffic Director
makes it super easy to just
automatically failover.
So you've got your retail
front end, your shopping
cart, your payments.
Each of these are hosted
in multiple regions
so that you can meet those
goals around latency,
around costs, high availability.
And so customers are
using Traffic Director
in combination with other
GCP products as well.
What you see here on
the left-hand side
is the global load balancer.
So this might be a global
HTTPS load balancer,
and what that does is it
gives you an IP address
that your clients on the public
internet can send traffic to.
And so that might look
something like this.
Your client sends traffic to
your global load balancer.
And lets say your client
happens to be in us-central1.
Well, the global load
balancer's smart enough
to send that traffic
to us-central1.
That minimizes latency.
That minimizes cost.
And so now your
retail front end,
which is what they're
interacting with--
they add something to
their shopping cart,
and your retail
front end needs to be
able to reach the shopping cart.
That shopping cart might
be on Compute Engine.
And it might just happen that
for some reason in us-central1,
well, your shopping
cart is down.
Maybe you deployed a new
version of your service
that didn't work.
Maybe you've got some
planned downtime.
And so what would
happen here is rather
than having your retail
front end send traffic
to the shopping cart and hit
errors for that end user,
that traffic just goes
to your shopping cart
in asia-southeast1.
It just fails over
seamlessly to another region.
And this is actually
pretty straightforward
to set up in Traffic Director.
You just add back ends
in multiple regions
as part of your service,
and Traffic Director
will make sure that
your retail front
end knows how to reach
the ones that are healthy.
And so the shopping cart can
go to your payment service.
All's good.
Your customer gets
served despite the fact
that your shopping
cart in us-central1
happened to be down.
That automatic failover
for high availability,
super critical in
the type of business
where you have to make sure
that every request is handled
in a high-quality way and gives
a good end-user experience
because if that
doesn't happen, that's
money left on the table
for you as a business.
Another use case I see--
I've got a customer who's one
of the world's leading logistics
providers is that
they have to make sure
that when they deploy a
new version of the service,
they don't have any downtime.
And so just for a
little bit of context
here, this customer has a
prediction service running,
and what that service
does is it tries
to figure out when a package
is going to be delivered.
Well, they do that by training
a machine-learning model
and deploying that model as
part of a workload that's
running on Kubernetes Engine.
They need to retrain that
model every once in a while
and redeploy that.
And so what that means is
when they do that deployment,
they need to make sure that
that model actually works
and that the deployment
happens successfully.
Anyone who's done deployments
knows that a deployment
is inherently risky.
You might try to make sure
that you have a development
environment, a staging
environment, a production
environment, and sort of
qualify that new version as it
goes through, but no two
environments are identical.
And so even if do everything
in staging and validate
that it works in
staging, there's
still some risk that once
you get to production,
it's going to go down.
And so this is a great example
of how we see customers
using Traffic Director.
In this example, the front
end is sending traffic
to the prediction service.
There's a Prediction v1 which
is the old version, Prediction
v2 which is the new
version of the model.
The customer has set
a traffic-split policy
which causes the front end to
send a percentage of traffic
to the old one, a percentage
of traffic to the new one.
And as you validate
that the model is good,
you can continue to increase
that percentage of traffic.
And so suddenly your
deployments are a lot safer
because you only subjected
a small percentage
of your traffic to
the new version.
You've checked that it worked.
If it didn't actually
work, well, you
can flip that back to
100% to the old version.
This gives you a lot of
safety around your deployments
It also unlocks all kinds
of really interesting DevOps
patterns like
blue-green deployments,
canary deployments.
These are the types of
things that organizations
are doing these
days, and you can
use Traffic Director to deliver
those types of use cases.
Another really interesting one
is this idea of network edge
services for GCP.
And also this is new for
non-GCP environments,
and I'll talk a little
bit more about what
I mean by network edge
services in both GCP
and non-GCP environments.
So I've got plenty of
customers-- large banks,
for example, who have
services that run in GCP,
and they also have services that
run in their own on-prem data
center.
And that might be
a temporary state
as they're migrating
everything to the cloud,
but it also might be
a permanent state.
There are all kinds of
really valid and good reasons
why you might want to have
some workloads in the cloud
and some workloads in on prem.
And this is great, right?
It makes a lot of sense.
One of the things that
customers come to GCP for
is our global load
balancer, and this
is similar-- this is the same
as what I mentioned earlier.
And this global load
balancer is the thing
that delivers to you this
group of services that I
call network edge services.
And so what do I mean by that?
I mean that when a client sends
traffic to the global load
balancer, there's all kinds of
different policies and services
that you can apply there.
An example is Cloud Armor.
You want to make sure that you
have DDoS protection in place
so that your clients
on the public internet
aren't overloading
your back ends,
and so this checks to make
sure that the traffic that's
coming in is safe.
You might have Cloud CDN
for content distribution.
So this helps you deliver
results more quickly
to your end users.
It also saves you
a bunch of costs
by caching different
static assets that are
delivered by the load balancer.
And the load balancer
also has all kinds
of really interesting
features built
into it, things like
a global Anycast VIP
so that you get a single IP
address that you can use around
the world, and your clients can
just address that IP address.
It'll go to the
closest instance,
and that's how you minimize that
latency, minimize that cost.
And I mentioned these things
because customers look at this
and they go great.
I can use all of this
with my cloud service.
I can make sure that if I have
a cloud service, it's protected.
I'm caching things
the right way.
But I as a bank, for
example, don't really
have that same global
footprint that GCP has.
I don't have points of presence
all across the world where
I can deliver a global
Anycast VIP where
I can do different security
mechanisms that are technically
or for cost reasons infeasible
for me to deliver myself.
Well, wouldn't it be great
if you could actually
have that for your
on-premises services as well?
And so one of the things
that we see as very critical
for Traffic Director
is the ability
to support more than just GCP.
And so today what
I'm showing you
is the ability to actually
use those edge services
with your on-prem services.
And so what does that look like?
Well, that looks like a pool
of proxies deployed here
on a Compute Engine-managed
instance group.
That managed instance
group is just
part of our infrastructure.
It scales up and
down dynamically.
Each of those is
running a proxy,
and it acts as a middle
proxy load balancer.
It connects to Traffic
Director to get configuration.
An example of the
type of configuration
would be, hey, there are
these on-premises endpoints,
each of them belonging
to the on-prem service
that you see on the
right-hand side.
Traffic Director knows
about that because you've
configured it that way.
Traffic Director lets
the proxy know about it.
And so now the next time
a client sends traffic
to the global load
balancer, that traffic
can go into the middle proxy.
That proxy then
forwards the traffic
onto your on-prem service.
And so this is a
really powerful use
case where you can get things
like Cloud Armor, Cloud
CDN, and global Anycast
VIP, these network
edge services for both
GCP services and services
running in non-GCP environments.
We also see-- this is a
key investment for us which
is this infrastructure
is really interesting,
but how do you go
from zero to deployed?
Well, we want to make
that as easy as possible,
and so what you see
here is the current way
of deploying something that
you would call a service mesh.
You have some Compute
Engine services.
These could be
Kubernetes as well.
You've got maybe a front
end and a back end.
Each of them has
a sidecar proxy.
And setting this up,
it's not that hard,
but it does require
some thought.
Where do I get this proxy?
What's the version
that I want to use?
How do I make sure
the version is secure
and I keep it up to date?
You have to do things
like configure IP tables.
And if you're like
me, before I started
even looking at
Traffic Director,
I had never even
messed with IP tables.
And I talked to
customers who are like,
this thing is really scary
because if you misconfigure it,
well, you can suddenly drop
a whole bunch of traffic,
and you don't want
to have to do that.
And so a lot of customers
find that deploying
sidecar proxies, not the
easiest thing in the world.
So we want to make that
a lot easier for you.
And so another thing that
I'm showing here today
is a new way of deploying
your sidecar proxies.
And a really easy way to
think about it is it's
basically a virtual
machine template.
It's a virtual machine
template that you
control with some flags,
with some parameters--
--service-proxy enabled.
And what that will do
is it will automatically
onto your virtual
machines, which
could be running a client
application or a server
application too--
onto those virtual
machines, the template
will install Envoy, a recent
version that we've qualified.
It will connect it
to Traffic Director.
It will do things like
set up IP tables for you
so you don't have to deal
with things that might be very
foreign to you
which, again, have
very little to do with actually
delivering your services.
And it gives you a really
easy way to do updates.
It's as easy as issuing
a couple of commands
to initiate a rolling update.
You don't need to think
about picking an Envoy,
compiling that Envoy,
the Envoy proxy,
compiling it, deploying
it, setting things up.
That's all handled for you.
And so another thing
that we're announcing--
and Kelsey showed
this before-- is
this idea of using an
application library instead
of an Envoy proxy.
We've got Traffic
Director support
for proxyless gRPC services.
And what do I mean by that?
What I mean by that is
if you look at the most
recent versions of
gRPC, they support
this protocol called xDS.
XDS is a group of
APIs that are used
by Traffic Director, the
control plane, and things
like the Envoy proxy or
like gRPC to exchange
information about the
world, about the network,
about your topology, about
what the endpoints are
that you want to reach.
And so much the same way as
when you have Envoy deployed,
when you're using a
recent version of gRPC,
you can provide it some
configuration when you start it
up.
You use a different
xDS resolver.
It connects to Traffic Director.
Traffic Director
tells that proxy
what are the different endpoints
associated with the services
that you're trying to reach?
Because you'll notice very
quickly if you've used gRPC
before, it's a super-powerful
application framework,
but it doesn't come
with everything
that you need to do a
distributed service.
You see a lot of customers
who are doing things
like adding an Envoy proxy.
So your application
goes to that Envoy proxy
which then sends the traffic,
and that's totally fine.
It's super feature rich.
It works really well
for a lot of customers.
But if you're finding
that adding an Envoy proxy
is something that maybe you
can't do for reasons like you
can't really add a
sidecar, you can't
mess with IP tables,
those types of things,
well, now you have another way
where if you're using gRPC,
you can very easily get the
benefits of service mesh
simply by updating
to a new version,
changing your resolver
to the xDS resolver,
and connecting it
to Traffic Director.
And this gives you already
straight out of the box service
discovery.
What are the endpoints
that I'm trying to reach?
It gives you load balancing.
And we're working on all kinds
of other interesting things
that are super relevant here,
things like more traffic
management, and so
stay tuned for that.
You're going to see
that the goal is
that we bring all of
the capabilities that
are relevant to gRPC that you
can get in something like Envoy
to gRPC as well.
So example benefits
here are much easier way
to adopt service mesh.
Also performance.
We found that, in
some cases, this
can be more performant than if
you have to go through an Envoy
proxy first.
And obviously this is going to
depend on your use case, what
you're doing exactly, but
also a very interesting thing
to explore, especially if
you're already thinking about
gRPC for performance benefits.
This can get you even further.
And so with that, I
want to wrap it up
and say thank you very
much for listening today.
If you've got questions,
there's a Dory where
you can ask those questions.
We'll be looking
at the questions,
trying to get them
answered for you.
If you're new to Traffic
Director, check out the docs.
There's a setup guide
that walks you through end
to end how this stuff works.
And also some of the things
that I showed you today
may not be released yet at
the time where this comes out.
So if you have questions,
drop them in the Dory,
or I created this
form that you can use.
Go to the form.
Check it out.
You can request access, and
we'll try to get back to you
as soon as possible.
So with that, I
want to say thank
you very much for having me.
Big shoutout to the
Traffic Director
team who keeps pushing
this product forward.
Thanks, Kelsey, for helping
us with the demo today.
And that's it for me.